PRESIDENT TRUMP TAKING TIME
DURING HIS VISIT TO THE U.K. TO
SIT DOWN FOR A CANDID INTERVIEW
WITH PIERS MORGAN ON "THE
GOOD MORNING BRITAIN" SHELTER HE
OPENED UP ABOUT HIS TRIP,
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE QUEEN AND
HOW HIS LATE MOTHER WOULD HAVE
REACTED.
>> I WILL SAY MY MOTHER WOULD
HAVE BEEN VERY PROUD OF.
SHE WAS A TREMENDOUS FAN OF THIS
COUNTRY AND SHE LOVED SCOTLAND.
SHE LOVELY ROYALS.
SHE LOVES THE QUEEN.
AND I ALWAYS NOTICE WHENEVER
ANYTHING WAS ON ABOUT THE QUEEN,
SHE WOULD WATCH.
SHE WAS A BIG FAN.
>> DID YOU TELL THE QUEEN?
STICK I TOLD HER LAST NIGHT.
SHE WAS VERY HONORED.
WE HAD A GREAT RAPPORT.
WE HAD A CONVERSATION THAT
LASTED FOR AN HOUR AND A HALF
NONSTOP.
>> Jesse: HE ALSO TOOK A
MOMENT TO CLARIFY A
CONTROVERSIAL COMMENT ABOUT
MEGHAN MARKLE, THE DUCHESS OF
SUSSEX.
>> DO YOU THINK MEGHAN MARKLE IS
NASTY OR NOT?
>> NOEL.
THE QUESTION WAS ASKED ABOUT ME
AND I DIDN'T KNOW THAT SHE SAID
ANYTHING BAD ABOUT ME.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE DID.
IT'S OKAY.
JOIN THE CROWD.
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE SHE HAD AND THEY
SAID SOME OF THE THINGS THAT SHE
SAID, AND IT'S ACTUALLY ON TAPE.
I'M I SAID WELL, I DIDN'T KNOW
SHE WAS NASTY.
I SAID SHE WAS NASTY ABOUT ME.
ESSENTIALLY I DIDN'T KNOW SHE
WAS NASTY ABOUT ME.
SO I SAID YOU KNOW WHAT SHE'S
DOING A GOOD JOB.
I HOPE SHE ENJOYS HER LIFE.
>> Jesse: OBVIOUSLY THE
PRESIDENT'S TRIP WAS COVERED
HEAVILY HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
BLASTING THE "CORRUPT" MEDIA FOR
NOT BEING FAIR.
THOSE COMMENTS NOT WITHOUT
MERIT.
LET'S LOOK AT THE DIFFERENCE IN
HOW THE BRITISH MEDIA IS
COVERING THE PRESIDENT COMPARED
TO THE U.S.
U.K. OUTLETS OPTING FOR MORE
POSITIVE HEADLINES, TRUMP'S
PRAISE OF INTERNAL PROJECT,
COMMON VALUES, AND THE TREASURED
VENTURE BETWEEN THE U.S. AND THE
U.K.
THE U.S. MEDIA, THEY JUST CAN'T
SEEM TO HELP THEMSELVES.
ONCE AGAIN GOING ON THE ATTACK.
>> NARCISSISM DON'T MIX WELL
WITH DIPLOMACY.
WHO KNEW.
>> THE BRITS KNOW HOW TO TROLL
THE PRESIDENT.
THEY KNOW HOW TO GET UNDER HIS
SKIN.
THEY DID IT WITH STYLE,
SPECTACLE.
>> LIKES THE IDEA OF BEING A
KING.
>> PERHAPS HE LIKES THE IDEA OF
BEING A KING.
>> HE'S WALKING AROUND LIKE HE
WANTS TO BE THE KING.
LIKE HE'S THE KING.
TO HIS SUBJECTS, DO THIS, DO
THIS.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, DANA.
I THINK IT'S CLEAR WHY THE
BRITISH MEDIA LIKE IT WHEN THE
U.S. PRESIDENT COMES.
IT SOLIDIFIES THE RELATIONSHIP.
>> Dana: FOLLOWING BRITISH
POLITICS OVER THE PAST YEAR,
IT'S NOT BEEN EASY.
NOW I HAVE A PRIME MINISTER
LEAVING.
A NEW ELECTION.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE BREXIT.
IT'S A BIG MESS.
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL DAYS, THEY
ARE THE HOST TO THE LEADER OF
THE FREE WORLD.
IT COULD NOT HAVE GONE BETTER I
THINK.
THE U.K.'S PERSPECTIVE, AND ALSO
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE'S
PERSPECTIVE.
FOR U.S. MEDIA, IT'S PREBAKES
THAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
HAVE A BAD TRIP.
HE'S GOING TO SCREW SOMETHING
UP.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE A DOMESTIC
PROBLEM BACK HOME.
THAT'S ACTUALLY KIND OF NOT
HAPPEN.
OF COURSE, YOU KNOW PETER IS
BRITISH.
HE SAID THERE IS MORE OF A
GROUNDSWELL OF SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN BRITAIN THAT
A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE WHO WANTED
TO LEAVE THE EUROPEAN UNION GET
IGNORED IN THE MEDIA.
IT'S A VERY SIMILAR STORY.
THEY WISH THAT THERESA MAY HAD
BEEN A LITTLE BIT MORE LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHEN SHE WAS
FIGHTING WITH THE E.U. ABOUT
LEAVING.
SHE KEPT TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE
AND THEY DON'T WANT TO
ACCOMMODATE EUROPE ANYMORE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT GOES FROM
HERE BUT I THINK THE U.K. HAD A
VERY SUCCESSFUL VISIT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS A LOT TO BE
PROUD OF AND THERE IS STILL MORE
TO COME.
TO BE
>> Jesse: VIDEO FOR YOU OF THE
PRESIDENT TRYING ON A HAT.
>> WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT YOU
WITH A CHURCHILL HAT.
>> I NEVER KNEW YOU HAD THAT
KIND OF SENSIBILITY.
LET ME TRY THIS ON.
IT'S A LITTLE BIG.
>> THAT'S FANTASTIC.
>> LET'S SEE HOW THIS LOOKS.
>> WINSTON TRUMP.
BIG I THINK WINSTON LOOKED
BETTER IN IT.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
THAT, GREG?
>> Greg: HE SHOULD BE WILLING
A BLACK HAT.
I NEVER LIKED PIERS MORGAN ON
CNN BUT I LIKE HIM ON THAT SHOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE DELUSION.
ONE OF THE WOMEN IN THE MONTAGE
THAT SAID THE BRITS REALLY KNOW
HOW TO GET IT UNDER HIS SKIN.
THAT'S A DELUSION.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY SIGN THAT
ANYTHING WAS UNDER HIS SKIN BUT
SHE SEES IT IN HER HEAD AND
PROJECTS IT.
THERE'S AN ARTICLE ON CNN THAT
WE ALL GOT SENT AROUND.
31 QUOTES FROM DONALD TRUMP.
AFTER EACH QUOTE COME HIS HEAD
WAS EXPLODING.
YOU COULD HEAR HIM PULLING AT
HIS HAIR.
HE'S LIKE THE NEIGHBOR AT
BEWITCHED.
HE'S GOING NUTS.
WHEN YOU FOCUS ON THE WORDS YOU
CREATE YOUR VERY OWN MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM THAT NOBODY ELSE
CAN SEE.
IF YOU FOCUS ON THE DEEDS,
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH TRADE,
JOBS, GDP, NORTH KOREA, CHINA,
WHAT WE ARE DOING WITH OPIOIDS.
MILITARY STRENGTH.
THIS IS A GOLDEN AGE.
IF YOU KEEP FOCUSING ON THE
WORDS YOU END UP HAVING THESE
DELUSIONS LIKE YOU DO ON CNN
UNLIKE THIS YOUNG WOMAN ON THAT
OTHER SHOW.
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO SAY, I HAVE
SAID BEFORE THAT TRUMP IS A NEWS
POTATO.
YOU CAN MAKE HIM INTO AN EMAIL.
FRENCH FRIES, AU GRATIN,
SHEPHERD'S PIE.
HE SERVED IT UP.
A HEARTY BLEND OF NEWS AND
ENTERTAINMENT.
>> Jesse: JUAN, WHAT WOULD YOU
MAKE THE PRESIDENT INTO IF YOU
ARE PLAYING MR. POTATO HEAD.
>> Juan: SHEPHERD'S PIE.
YOU ARE SOPHISTICATED GUY, GREG.
>> Greg: I LIKE SHEPHERD'S
PIE.
IT'S NOT WHAT YOU THINK, BY THE
WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I SAW IT DIFFERENTLY.
I READ WHERE THE PRESIDENT WAS
TALKING TO THERESA MAY.
WE COULD HAVE A TRADE DEAL WITH
THE U.S.
WE WILL INCLUDE THE BRITISH
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WHICH SET
PAIR OF FIRE IN BRITAIN.
WHAT?
HE WANTS TO BRING AMERICAN
PRIVATE ENTERPRISE INTO OUR MUCH
BELOVED PUBLIC-SECTOR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
I THINK PEOPLE WERE UPSET ABOUT
IT.
WITH THE MEGHAN MARKLE STUFF, HE
SAYS HE WAS TALKING ON HER
COMMENT.
I THINK IS THIS A DIFFERENCE
WITHOUT DISTINCTION?
HE HAS A HISTORY OF CALLING
PEOPLE LIKE HILLARY CLINTON AND
NASTY WOMAN.
HE SAID ABOUT ELIZABETH WARREN
AND KAMALA HARRIS.
HE SAYS OMAROSA IS A DOG, ROSIE
O'DONNELL.
I KNOW HOW THIS GUY TALKS AND
SPEAKS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
CRITICAL OR HAVE STRONG
DIFFERENCES WITH HIM.
SO TO ME --
>> Jesse: HE SAYS THAT ABOUT
MEN TOO.
>> Juan: OKAY, THAT'S MY
POINT.
IN OTHER WORDS, SHE'S THE KIND
OF PERSON WHO MAKES NASTY
COMMENTS TO HIM.
>> Greg: TO HIM.
HE TELLS YOU WHAT HE'S THINKING.
>> Juan: YOU SAY EVERYTHING
WENT SO SMOOTHLY BUT I THINK YOU
LOOK AT THE PROTESTS.
HE SAID HE NEVER SAW IT.
HE SAID HE SAW PEOPLE CHEERING.
BUT I SEE --
>> Dana: THEY WEREN'T THAT
BIG.
>> Juan: COMPARED TO WHAT THEY
MIGHT'VE BEEN.
SEE FIVE CONSIDERING THE OUTRAGE
ON THE POINT.
>> Greg: OF THE BUILDUP OF THE
MEDIA.
>> Kennedy: THAT THE MAYOR OF
LONDON WAS MAKING, YOU THINK THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WAS DEAD SET
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT AND HE IS
AS BAD AS HITLER.
THINLY VEILED TOPIC OF SADIQ
KHAN'S OP-ED.
I WANT TO POINT OUT IN CONTRAST,
HOW YOU FEEL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT
AND HOW HE HAS JOSTLED THE WORLD
STAGE.
U.S. POLITICS IS VERY DYNAMIC,
VERY, VERY FLUID.
WE KNOW WE MAY HAVE A NEW
PRESIDENT IN A YEAR AND A HALF
BUT WE MAY HAVE THE SAME
PRESIDENT FOR ANOTHER FIVE AND A
HALF YEARS.
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN THERE THROUGH
MANY ADMINISTRATIONS IS THE
QUEEN.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT HER REACTION
AND HER REACTION WAS NOT ONE OF
DISGUST OR DISDAIN OR SNOBBERY.
SHE WAS TRULY GIDDY.
SHE OBVIOUSLY ENJOYED BEING IN
HIS PRESENCE BECAUSE SHE KNOWS
THIS TOO SHALL PASS AND NOT TO
GET TOO WRAPPED UP AND TO
EMOTIONAL INTO REACTIVE TO THIS
FIGURE WHO'S CREATED ALL SORTS
OF EMOTIONAL REACTIONS.
FROM PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF
HATRED AND BELOVED FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
I REALLY ENJOYED WATCHING HER.
I DON'T THINK SHE WAS TROLLING
HIM.
HE THINK SHE HAD A GREAT TIME TO
THINK SHE'S AT A POINT IN HER
LIFE WHERE FROM EISENHOWER TECH
TRUMP, SHE HAS SEEN THE
POLITICAL GAMBIT RUN HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Juan: YOU THOUGHT SHE MIGHT
BE TROLLING HIM?
>> Kennedy: THAT WAS THE POINT
OF ONE OF THE FIRST COMMENTERS
SAYING THE BRITS REALLY KNOW HOW
TO CONTROL THE PRESIDENT.
THAT WASN'T TROLLING.
THAT WAS SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN
THROUGH IT WHO HAS PERSPECTIVE
WHO ACTUALLY HAD A PRETTY GOOD
TIME.
>> Jesse: KENNEDY KNOWS
TROLLING.
>> Greg: I AM ACTUALLY A
TROLL.
I LIVE UNDER A BRIDGE.